Trascrizione: Federico Maggi
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Ho una domanda, per tutti voi.
Guardate queste immagini.
Quali differenze notate?
Forse, in un primo momento,
non vi sembra che ci siano differenze:
sono due campi,
come tanti di quelli
che incontriamo nella nostra pianura.
Verdissimi.
Eppure, le differenze ci sono,
e io oggi sono qui per farvele scoprire.
A sinistra abbiamo un prato foraggero,
un prato che: è destinato prettamente
all'alimentazione del bestiame;
produce una notevole quantità di foraggio;
si taglia una volta sola.
A destra, un prato stabile.
Avete mai sentito parlare
di "prati stabili"?
I Prati Stabili della Valle del Mincio
ricoprono qualche migliaio di ettari.
E partono da Cavriana, Volta Mantovana;
si concentrano a Goito, Marmirolo,
fino alla città,
costeggiando il fiume Mincio.
Ecco, questa è la prima differenza:
i prati stabili non sono ovunque.
Seconda differenza:
se un prato foraggero
dura sei mesi, due stagioni,
un prato stabile dura anche cent'anni.
Addirittura, le loro età
vengono tramandate tra le generazioni
di chi lo ha coltivato.
Terza differenza:
un prato foraggero è verde
per due stagioni, sei mesi;
un prato stabile è verde sempre.
Se nel prato foraggero abbiamo 20 essenze,
nel prato stabile ne troviamo oltre 60.
Ma veniamo alla differenza più importante:
un prato foraggero,
dopo il raccolto, si ara;
un prato stabile no.
Un prato foraggero si semina;
un prato stabile, no.
Ma perché non si ara,
e non si semina, un prato stabile?
Perché si rigenera.
Si rigenera!
E cosa significa che si rigenera?
Significa che, grazie
all'azione dell'acqua,
i semi dell'erba matura
si propagano ovunque,
dando nuova forza e vigore al prato.
Ma per raccontarvi
quanto è importante l'acqua,
perché l'acqua è la fonte rigenerativa,
vi devo fare un po' di storia.
Nel 1400, quando Andrea Mantegna
stava realizzando la Camera degli Sposi,
sul nostro territorio ci fu
una vera e propria
"febbre delle bonifiche":
vista la grande disponibilità di acqua
che scorreva nel fiume Mincio,
furono realizzate le più grandi
opere idrauliche di quel tempo.
Una fittissima rete di canali
ha permesso di distribuire l'acqua
su tutto il nostro territorio.
Con le macine del grano,
l'Amministrazione Centrale
percepiva le tasse,
e governava i territori.
Se nel 1600 c'erano 14 mulini,
a metà del 1800 80 ruote mosse dall'acqua
macinavano e producevano forza motrice.
Il livellamento dei terreni ha favorito
l'irrigazione a scorrimento,
dove l’acqua, mossa
dalla forza di gravità,
ha garantito e garantisce
lo sviluppo dei prati.
Una sottile lama d'acqua
scivola sul terreno, irrigandolo,
favorendo la cosa più importante,
che è la semina naturale.
Perché i semi dell'erba matura,
che cadono nel campo,
poi grazie all'acqua si diffondono
anche nelle aree più remote.
E dando, sempre, nuova vita al terreno.
Pensate che in un metro quadro
di prato stabile
ci sono oltre 400 specie,
tra flora, fauna, microrganismi,
che animano, popolano questo terreno,
rendendo il prato stabile
rigoglioso e verde.
In questi 50 centimetri di terreno,
i microrganismi trasformano
la sostanza organica
in alimento per la pianta.
Pensate che, in un metro quadro
di prato stabile,
sono fissati al suolo
oltre 18 chilogrammi di carbonio.
Esattamente il 25% in più
di un prato foraggero.
Le 60 essenze del prato stabile
crescono con la primavera,
già con le temperature ancora fresche;
e producono un prodotto
ricco e rigoglioso.
Questo prodotto viene tagliato in maggio,
ed è il cosiddetto maggengo.
L'erba, una volta tagliata,
e distesa al suolo,
si impoverisce di umidità
grazie all'azione del sole,
e si arricchisce di profumi.
In tre giorni, l'erba diventa fieno:
e può essere, una volta raccolta,
conservata per anni.
Ma immaginate un attimo questo scenario.
È una sera di maggio,
una di quelle sere in cui il sole
si attarda nel giorno
e illumina, per gli ultimi minuti,
il prato dov'è disteso il fieno,
che perde il calore della giornata.
Sentite quel profumo caldo, profondo,
ancestrale del fieno.
Quel profumo che ti trascina nei ricordi,
e ti fa tornare bambino.
Un'emozione forte, un'emozione
che a volte rigenera la tua identità.
I prati stabili sono un immenso
patrimonio di biodiversità.
I prati stabili devono essere curati:
senza la cura dell'uomo, il prato muore.
I prati li abbiamo trovati così.
I figli li han visti
come li han visti i padri, e i nonni;
e come i nonni e i padri,
continuano a prendersene cura.
Ora vi faccio vedere una persona
che se n'è presa cura per oltre 70 anni.
(Video)
Gesti antichi, che legano le generazioni.
Ma non solo: i prati stabili
hanno risvegliato il territorio.
Si sono condivisi i progetti;
le famiglie si sono animate;
le aziende anche;
gli enti locali pure.
Sono stati costruiti progetti.
Oggi questi progetti sono diventati
realtà, investimenti, sviluppo.
I Comuni hanno realizzato
delle piste ciclabili,
per valorizzare l'enogastronomia
del nostro territorio.
Si sono realizzati eventi,
grazie ai giovani.
I giovani hanno sviluppato
attività didattiche.
Con i bambini,
oggi sono diventati la forza motrice
che porta avanti questa tradizione.
Oggi abbiamo realizzato attività
le più varie possibili,
tra le quali concerti in un prato stabile,
in un anfiteatro costruito con il fieno.
Dunque, stiamo parlando di un'economia
fatta di attività, di sviluppo,
di ricerca e di impegno.
Ed è un'agricoltura fatta di connessioni.
Là dove enti pubblici e privati,
latterie, cooperative
hanno dato il massimo per dare
lo sviluppo a questo territorio.
Ora avete capito, quali sono
le differenze tra questi due prati?
Ed è per questo, che vi voglio raccontare
che queste aziende, questi enti,
hanno deciso di candidare
i Prati Stabili della Valle del Mincio
a Patrimonio dell'Umanità.
Io penso che chiunque abbia a cuore
l'agricoltura rigenerativa
sarà pronto ad accettare
questo passaggio, e questa scommessa.
I prati stabili,
con la loro forza rigenerativa,
ci insegnano che bisogna
guardare al passato
per cercare di esprimere, e di capire,
tutte quelle esperienze
che ci possono dare una luce
per un futuro sostenibile.
La storia che vi ho raccontato
vuole dire che a volte
bisogna girarci, e rigenerare lo sguardo.
per vedere delle cose così preziose,
che noi dobbiamo curare e custodire.
I prati stabili:
la terra, come dovrebbe essere.
Grazie.
(Applausi)